christopher waters save Robert Henry hi
we are playing wolfenstein z oz nap old
blood new game new dlc standalone 20
bones planning on xbox one it's out on
pc and ps4 today and we're shooting some
Nazis we are in ceiling now starting now
Chris yeah how much have you played okay
i'm like halfway I'm like near the end
of chapter 2 I would say is a good
estimate for where I am in this game
okay and already then the Nazis have
beset me Oh God okay all right all right
let's just let's just cool it for a
second in here this is a good place to
hang out yeah it is I get my dual wield
out so all right we're in again we're in
Castle Wolfenstein okay its 1946 the war
is not going well but i did get this
sick new pistol that shoots explosives
fantastic do one Nazis so is this a
official prequel yeah free pool okay for
recalls so I know the first one he comes
in on a plane spoiler alert ya know this
is uh this is like a special mish okay
special mission that he's on to get some
oh god hmm what did why did it stop
shooting good there he's trying to steal
some stuff from inside Castle
Wolfenstein okay I need some more armor
or health is it in a box yes you mean
this they eat this cat food so you're
stealing some plans you're going in solo
or maybe you had some dudes always so
this is the first hole first bit was
actually a stealth sequence of like um
infiltrating and then I got caught but
now I'm like it breaking out and try to
find the buddy who I was hanging out
with off what's up friend and so I found
him he's been extracted too oh god mmm
gas tank there go everyone exploded
honest Oh what are you doing in here
this is my safety helmets closet was
that move I just saw that melee was at
it that your put your pipe I was a quick
little net knife melee but now that you
mention it I do have a pipe right oh god
this is bad this is
not a good time for you to show me to
show of you my bike from I gotta say I'm
sorry oh crap crap crap crap crap okay
regenerate health regen our health
there's health right around here digging
yeah okay okay cool yeah so this is like
the this is close to when it starts like
opening up and being more of the shooter
action type situation that we all know
and love from the new orders over here
oh no I have my pipe as my alternate yet
I wanted my exploding gun so yeah you
guys so you got the pipe I saw you had a
little grenade launcher pistol yeah
that's like the new gun that I've
encountered thus far the pipe has been
helpful in terms of the stealth
situation it's like a stealth I they
count around behind me yeah sure it's
like us you get stabbed people with it
you can also uh clobber people with it
you can break it apart and put it back
together you can use it to climb walls
and like pry open doors to get into
different areas that seems pretty vers
it's very useful it's a helpful pipe mmm
can I preserve my health and armor a
little bit better this time this looks
like a souped-up SG excuse me STG 44
right and it was this for mine was this
from the new order I forget well so
here's machine gun here's the thing man
like the new order technically is after
this game sobre OS up dummy this is
technically like an earlier version of
the gun that uh oh god there that you
get a taste of right before you pass out
and go unconscious in a coma that's in
the sixties that's the stuff exactly so
yeah this is these are more akin to the
oh god this is not good I can't use my
gun I'm dying in the lake this is a kin
to the weapons you get in the pre yeah
in that sort of first level of the new
order and also you see that it's a
prequel in a couple different ways it's
um you know there's the ponds er the
compound like the the doggies that they
made all messed up rather they're
terrible it it
nice why don't I use this thing all the
time what am I thinking oh my god couple
you back there in there I thought some
blood spray may be all right back i love
it down there they aren't like they
aren't the full robot dogs that you're
used to shooting in the new order
they're like you can see they have fuzzy
ears and it makes you feel a little bit
worse about killing them but not that
much worse because they're still gnarly
I'm going to put on some extra hats
mm-hmm best situation this area seems
clear let's let's move forward basically
i infiltrated here with my buddy Wes
trying to steal some in trying to get
into the like this is where we're
tapping into these sort of paranormal
stuff that prove that other Wolfenstein
games have have checked out a little
clothes half into yeah yeah like in in
the Wolfenstein 2009 there was like
straight-up magic powers that you could
wield I don't know if that's gonna
happen but this is definitely like the
sort of stuff that I'm finding a round
that's like the notes and what have you
are definitely along the lines of the
occult that you know the Nazis were into
that we've seen in multiple different
forms of Nazi representation including
Indiana Jones so is this like the same
kind of cult that was in new order which
basically the Nazis tapped into which
led them to create all the super
technology and yeah the super technology
stuff is already starting to happen like
you know those there's super soldier
dudes with the giant mini guns and the
horrible skin problems yep those guys
are in this but oh man there's like an
earlier phase yeah they're like tethered
they're like they basically are like
like buses that run on wire electric
wires overhead like they're tethered and
who is who is still around and so you
have to like shut down the generator
that's powering them and then there you
are
and then once you've done that you can
take them out with your plate I've
gotten that wave of dudes knocked out
the box here this is the part that I
don't know this isn't my favorite part
about the new order is like once all
these guys are dead and you need to
replenish armor you just kind of walk
around looking at the ground and tapping
x yeah but it doesn't take that long as
you can see I'm pretty much already
maxed out with all my stuff let me just
get real cooz DUP on health here mm-hmm
and let's go to the next part which is I
think hopefully it's riding in this
sweet boat right here cool can I can I
go on the boat looks like you're gonna
want the challenge prison docks so yeah
the challenge oh no put it in the thing
yeah oh crap oh oh here we go yeah it's
ready so that there's challenges in this
which are like uh I guess I haven't
actually done one of them yeah we had a
little proto flying drones action uh you
just gets it like take on a certain area
and there's like sort of campaigns
they're scoring yeah so you know I guess
it probably judges on speed and maybe a
head shot accuracy and maybe you know
triple kills and stuff like that stuff
that it doesn't really surface as part
of the normal play um but that it would
probably have to if it was in scoring so
I from April check out some a little
later in it turn on their own boss okay
overall you say leg went away y'all know
leg parts anymore um would you say there
is a difference in gameplay if you can
remember a new order like I remember
hearing someone talk about how the guns
fell a little more like they had a
little bit more recoil or a little
clunky or I mean obviously it is taking
place prior to the 60s around yeah I
think maybe if I put them maybe if I
play them like back to back and had like
the slick new assault rifle you get in
new order versus the
building ones I've got going on here I
might be able to notice a difference but
you know it's been like almost a year
since I've played the new order so
that's yes so it's not like it the
difference is not at so drastic I think
there is like a rifle that you get in a
little bit that's a little longer range
so that might create some different sort
of gameplay moments and more sniping
situations okay I'm taking this gun with
me even though I will probably have to
unload it things it's like climb a
ladder or whatever alright yeah
definitely gonna hit that switch oh
we're gonna get a cut scene I'm toss
these pipes so is that like the first
weapon you start off with this is a pipe
it's one you have throughout the whole
self stealth section yeah okay once you
get thrown in the clink
oh hello mr. rat I've seen that report
oh yeah a little foreshadow alone at
friend maybe mmm chapter 2 don't now I
have I have to I'll leave this one here
I take that ladder with me know anything
else you get here cool no cool guns go
ahead back on the boat back on the boat
I'm just gonna put you here for
safekeeping mmm let's go boat let's take
me oh you stalking break into the key
kill every goddamn Nazi in today's is
this a new character no it's just bj
talking himself oh it is oh that's right
he did just like chat up within himself
wake up you're dead who's that in the
myriad it's just me handsome son of a
[ __ ] so are you approaching Castle
Wolfenstein right now so I'm I do you
approach in the very first scene uh this
is like I'm penetrating further into the
castle towards the keypad yes uh yeah
imma bring you won't bring you with
you're coming with I can get an angle on
this choke chacho up here so I remember
seeing like when the trailers and well
my favorite games actually of all time
is Return to Castle Wolfenstein sure and
I remember um you know you you're in the
castle and then there's a tram you take
to like exit the castle which you know
it's obviously snowy it's like that but
the shot that I saw looked almost
exactly like it oh yeah like right at
the beginning it's yeah one that's like
set in the mountainside exactly ya know
they're definitely trying to make trying
to connect it to I mean they're you know
come straight up connecting connecting
it to Wolfenstein past so there may even
be some Easter eggs that you recognize
here I didn't play too much Castle
Wolfenstein oh god who's going to come
out of there hopefully not some jerks so
i might not spot those as readily as you
but there's also other easter eggs
people been tweeting about the nuka-cola
in the vending machine from fallout and
then there's like a straight-up Skyrim
dragonborn helmet in one of the early
areas look just like kind of hanging out
Bethesda right yeah so there they've got
they've got no qualms with putting a
little some references and whatnot
especially with and so especially within
the wolfenstein sty no verse as a the
fans call it I made that up sorry it's
fine I like it cool yes so like no like
I'm probably not going to make it inside
there i just opened up that other area I
sense a boss fight going on here you
feel a little bossing I mean there's
like you know the Wolfenstein they did
the the sort of arena battle situations
right of you know creating a big open
space I'm a terrific take this map yeah
nice there's there's a ! that tells me
what's hot I'd go there if I were you
you got it buddy I think I am getting on
a different boat that leads me to a
different place but then why did I open
that door curiosity Rob and I was able
to throw that switch and open that door
it doesn't it follow that there's
something back there that I should check
out here hopefully there's not robot
lake dolphins or whatever prowls the
lasers with dolphins that shoot lasers I
wouldn't put it past them they're very
creative they have to be blue though
blue lasers no okay I feel like that's
what I've been seeing ah you know I
always feel I feel like the Nazis would
go for red sure all right so this is a
thing you can do with the pipe is uh
weird about pipette Oh bus it down BAM
give me through here damn thank God you
got that pipe woof now I'm over here and
going into this side of the area oh
here's another thing you can do with the
pipe wait should I go in here is the
other area a secret unclear gonna go in
here anyways so the pipes kind of
replacing your laser gun from new order
right yeah cuz that thing you know is
like a go hello sup all you dudes
um that's why I might buy blue they're
all like kind of blue yeah you got that
electro side that's a good point you
have a point you know um i'm just gonna
hang on your decision right I just want
them to come back because I didn't shoot
them quick enough in their domes I love
are they gonna come back yeah they'd
probably roll I really like this leaning
mechanic even though yes yes around the
world Oh what's up friend well that was
your head oh you have an armored man
nuts oh he is taking it took like ten
dust wow this guy I mean this guy right
here it's gonna take one so I just saw
you unlocked what some like character
art wasn't sure hello anybody bueller Oh
give me that what is that there's a
comma I was visit new weapon right
chanson trail this is like a hourly old
shotgun took a double-barrel
semi-automatic sure gonna find out right
now here we go wow that's a lot and it's
gone I used up all my mo trying to fill
that one dude it was such a great big
boat got that lean there guys did it it
it it it it it it putting everything
into the fly like the lunge all your
weight huh no what a nobody i'll look
for that thing just throw burn a doll
that's too close to me oh this is all
gone bad uh okay he's you're right a
grenade pistol i was no I had no mo
that's why I was panicking mm-hmm ok ok
ok ok ok look oh oh yes awkwardness
slide gotcha gotcha buddy ok whoo that
was not well not great not my best vegan
Oh No spoke too soon all right all right
all right all right you're good so
obviously you know this have you been
encountering this point in the game like
the classic like you know running gun or
stealth is
a lot of that going on both of those
things so I'm now like there was a whole
intro stealth section that i just did
not that I already beat okay dad I
wonder help anytime how many pipe hits
its gonna take to take out the
super-soul oh I'd love to see some pipe
action get it oh no get point you can
also block with the pipe oh yeah why I
probably can't block a shotgun but
little Perry hit quite punt time alright
three guys damn it that does not so good
you could say but quick loading times so
hey yeah but I boo alright pipe run hype
is awesome I'm not gonna do pipe this
time so for the deal see I thought we'd
get back to our roots just start with
the pipe it's like slowly shoot this
kind of face pink dang thang thang thang
thang ping ping ping oh I'm rockin out
the geesh whoops okay that was a wasted
grenade hey I think I heard something
any other room guys now I was nothing
step directly on that
okay give me the shock hammer back keep
the move yep so first oh yeah now this
is you this is what I want to be doing
is using this thing against the normies
right um so new order had like those
enigmas and such yes is there anything
about that or there is a there sort of
an illusion to maybe that stuff is gonna
happen um nice that armor okay uh in
sort of a note that i found earlier okay
so yeah nice no i don't think that was
the greatest they throw fairly good it's
a splash Rob I bad i'm sure you're
positive reinforcement yeah i got no
ammo for this so let's see you got
something in the chamber we're gonna
have this and we're gonna have this
ready to go anybody eight rounds Mueller
yeah thing you gotta wait they seem to
be relatively I think there's go Oh yep
yep okay okay lights out give me your
hat all of your hats are belong to me
yeah so this it's now like this is it's
sort of hitting its sweet spot now a
little earlier it was taking a little
time and I was getting a little antsy
long or Sweden signs of peace treaty
with Hitler ah it's not cool so yeah
this is it still does that kind of world
building stuff what I haven't really
encountered thus far is the like
character cutscenes that I really loved
in new order now granted this is still
pretty early on so that stuff could be
coming down the pipe you know I'm sorry
I've sort of been getting an idea for
who the villain is this woman Helga
who's off somewhere else at a she's at
like a dig site trying to find some
weird crap that's going on yeah so and
so I've sort of been getting the hang of
sort of been getting to know her but
haven't like seen her in action yet Hall
what's up don't you tell me to stop it
Oh
you it's one of you guys so I'm hoping
that more more villains stuff will come
oh wait gather already did a little
later on because that was one of the
things that I thought new order did
really well was made you have villains
you just like hated yeah kind of
interest there interesting what you like
Love date them yeah that's what I want
oh yeah that first scene or one for
scenes when you get aloft in the
incinerator room oh yeah death shed
death's-head yeah death's-head excuse me
that's shed nice it has a writ you don't
want to go to his shed man dude he'd
[ __ ] it is just not okay kids but when
he's peeking at you like through the
window you're locked in Oh creep yeah oh
man I remember such a creepy moments so
creepy like that I live jit amelia was
creeped out yeah like I remember playing
that in my room lights out headphones on
and just being me pics okay oh my god
this is weird what she back out here
there's more there's more man's alright
this is a situation where maybe I don't
want to be doing wielding want to do a
little 80s you could um I mean dual
wielding is very accurate because bj is
a Superman obviously but a whole god
this guy's a little close for comfort um
just do some of this Oh what you turned
into a normal guy or he was just behind
you okay we're cool were cool what do
you think little short shorted it short
behind the barrels he's hiding how dare
you observe my behavior and comment on
it
I have you run into a something similar
to new order where there was like a
split in the story path right like
cyborg I say one of the two look the
other one died ah no not yet okay but
this is so this oh yeah reload this is
the sort of first of two stories that
are contained within oh that's right and
so this one is the it happens here at
Castle Wolfenstein the other one happens
at this town called wolf berg i believe
and is really where we start to get into
some weird Nazi occult stuff so what
that is a will hold in store remains to
be seen the trailer sort of teased some
you like some strange creatures and
whatnot some zombie like behavior but
yeah there that's uh that's what's going
on in old blood Rob I'm gonna go in here
and try to shoot some more guys with my
sweet turret gun but I feel like I'm
going back here so that I could then go
try to open that big front door and get
in where the action is so I'm good yeah
cool man Wolfenstein the new blood xbox
one ps4 pc get it out now we got a
review coming on gamespot com in a
little bit what I think I uh I'm
intrigued man I was a huge new order fan
from last year is one my favorite games
of the year and then awesome shooter
good stuff still looks like it's got it
it's all there yeah it's and it still
feels kind of fresh like the the kind of
pace of the game play and the big arena
sort of areas that you run around and do
your dual wielding and whatnot that that
sort of brash formula like I not tired
of it glad to have more thanks machine
games
you